this is a video I've been excited to
make for a while now the story here
braids together prime numbers complex
numbers and pi in a very pleasing trio
quite often in modern math especially
that which flirts with the Riemann
zeta-function
these three seemingly unrelated objects
show up in unison and I want to give you
a little peek at one instance where this
happens one of the few that doesn't
require too heavy a technical background
that's not to say that this is easy in
fact this is probably one of the most
intricate videos I've ever done but the
culmination is worth it what we'll end
up with is a formula for pi a certain
alternating infinite sum this formula is
actually written on the mug that I'm
drinking coffee from right now as I
write this and a fun but almost
certainly apocryphal story is that the
beauty of this formula is what inspired
live nets to quit being a lawyer and
instead pursue math now whenever you see
PI show up in math there's always gonna
be a circle hiding somewhere sometimes
very sneakily
so the goal here is not just to discover
this sum but to really understand the
circle hiding behind it you see there is
another way that you can prove the same
result that you and I are gonna spend
some meaningful time building up to but
with just a few lines of calculus and
this is one of those proofs that leaves
you thinking okay I suppose that's true
but not really getting a sense for why
or for where the hidden circle is on the
path that you and I will take though
what you'll see is that the fundamental
truth behind this sum and the circle
that it hides is a certain regularity in
the way that Prime members behave when
you put them inside the complex numbers
to start the story imagine yourself with
nothing more than a pencil some paper
and a desire to find a formula for
computing pi there are countless ways
that you could approach this but as a
broad outline for the plotline here
you'll start by asking how many lattice
points of the plane sit inside a big
circle and then that question is going
to lead to asking about how to express
numbers as the sum of two squares which
in turn is going to lead us to factoring
integers inside the complex plane
from there we'll bring in this special
function named KY which is going to give
us a formula for pi that at first seems
to involve a crazy complicated pattern
dependent on the distribution of primes
but a slight shift in perspective
is going to simplify it dramatically and
expose the ultimate gold nugget it's a
lot but good math takes time and we'll
take it step by step
when I say lattice point what I mean is
a point a B on the plane where a and B
are both integers a spot where the grid
lines here cross if you draw a circle
centered at the origin let's say with
radius 10 how many lattice points would
you guess are inside that circle
well there's one lattice point for each
unit of area so the answer should be
approximately equal to the area of the
circle PI R squared which in this case
is PI times 10 squared and if it was a
really big circle like radius 1 million
you would expect this to be a much more
accurate estimate in the sense that the
percent error between the estimate PI R
squared and the actual count of lattice
points should get smaller what we're
going to try to do is find a second way
to answer the same question how many
lattice points are inside the circle
because that can lead to another way to
express the area of a circle and hence
another way to express PI and so you
play and you wonder and maybe especially
if you just watched a certain calculus
video you might try looking through
every possible ring that a lattice point
could sit on now if you think about it
for each one of these lattice points a B
its distance from the origin is the
square root of a squared plus B squared
and since a and B are both integers a
squared plus B squared is also some
integer so you only have to consider
rings whose radii are the square roots
of some whole number a radius of 0 just
gives you that single origin point if
you look at the radius 1 that hits for
different lattice points radius square
root of 2 well that also hits four
lattice points radius square root of 3
doesn't actually hit anything where root
of 4 again hits four lattice points a
radius square root of 5 actually hits 8
- points and what we want is a
systematic way to count how many lattice
points are on a given one of these rings
a given distance from the origin and
then to tally the malla and if you pause
and try this for a moment what you'll
find is that the pattern seems really
chaotic just very hard to find order
under here and that's a good sign that
some very interesting math is about to
come into play in fact as you'll see
this pattern is rooted in the
distribution of primes as an example
let's look at the ring with radius
square root of 25 it hits the point five
zero since five squared plus zero
squared is 25 it also hits 4 3 since 4
squared plus 3 squared gives 25 and
likewise it hits 3 4 and also 0 5 and
what's really happening here
is that you're counting how many pairs
of integers a B have the property that a
squared plus B squared equals 25
and looking at the circle it looks like
there's a total of 12 of them as another
example take a look at the ring with
radius square root 11 it doesn't hit any
lattice points and that corresponds to
the fact that you cannot find two
integers whose squares add up to 11 try
it
now many times in math when you see a
question that has to do with the 2d
plane it can be surprisingly fruitful to
just ask what it looks like when you
think of this plane as the set of all
complex numbers so instead of thinking
of this lattice point here as the pair
of integer coordinates 3 4 instead think
of it as the single complex number 3
plus 4i that way another way to think
about the sum of the squares of its
coordinates 3 squared plus 4 squared is
to multiply this number by 3 minus 4i
this is called it's complex conjugates
it's what you get by reflecting over the
real axis replacing I with negative I
and this might seem like a strange step
if you don't have much of a history with
complex numbers but describing this
distance as a product can be
unexpectedly useful it turns our
question into a factoring problem which
is ultimately why patterns among prime
numbers are going to come into play
algebraically this relation is
straightforward enough to verify you get
a 3 squared and then the 3 times minus
4i cancels out with the 4i times 3 and
then you have negative 4i squared which
because I squared is negative 1 becomes
plus 4 squared this is also quite nice
to see geometrically and if you're a
little rusty with how complex
multiplication works I do have another
video that goes more into detail about
why complex multiplication looks the way
that it does the way you might think
about a case like this is that the
number 3 plus 4i has a magnitude of 5
and some angle off of the horizontal and
what it means to multiply it by 3 minus
4i is to rotate by that same angle in
the opposite direction putting it on the
positive real axis and then to stretch
out by a factor of 5 which in this case
lands you on the output 25 the square of
the magnitude
the collection of all of these lattice
points a plus bi where a and B are
integers has a special name they're
called the Gaussian integers named after
Martin Sheen geometrically you'll still
be asking the same question how many of
these lattice points Gaussian integers
are a given distance away from the
origin like square root of 25 but we'll
be freezing it in a slightly more
algebraic way how many Gaussian integers
have the property that multiplying by
their complex conjugate gives you 25
this might seem needlessly complex but
it's the key to understanding the
seemingly random pattern for how many
lattice points are a given distance away
from the origin to see why we first need
to understand how numbers factor inside
the Gaussian integers as a refresher
among ordinary integers every number can
be factored as some unique collection of
prime numbers for example 2,250 can be
factored as 2 times 3 squared times 5
cubed and there is no other collection
of prime numbers that also multiplies to
make 2,250 unless you let negative
numbers into the picture in which case
you could just make some of the primes
in this factorization negative so really
within the integers factorization is not
perfectly unique it's almost unique with
the exception that you can get a
different looking product by multiplying
some of the factors by negative 1 the
reason I bring that up is that factoring
works very similarly inside the Gaussian
integers some numbers like 5 can be
factored into smaller Gaussian integers
which in this case is 2 plus I times 2
minus I this Gaussian integer here 2
plus I cannot be factored into anything
smaller so we call it a Gaussian Prime
again this factorization is almost
unique but this time not only can you
multiply each one of those factors by
negative 1 to get a factorization that
looks different
you can also be extra sneaky and
multiply one of these factors by eye and
then the other one by negative eye this
will give you a different way to factor
five into two distinct Gaussian Prime's
but other than the things that you can
get by multiplying some of these factors
by negative one or I or negative I
factorization within the Gaussian
integers is unique and if you can figure
out how ordinary prime numbers factor
inside the Gaussian integers that'll be
enough to tell us how any other natural
number factors inside these Gaussian
integers and so here we pull in a
crucial and pretty surprising fact prime
numbers that are one above a multiple of
four like five or 13 or 17 these guys
can always be factored into exactly two
distinct Gaussian Prime's this
corresponds with the fact that rings
with a radius equal to the square root
of one of these prime numbers always hit
some lattice points in fact they always
hit exactly eight lattice points as
you'll see in just a moment on the other
hand prime numbers that are three above
a multiple for like three or seven or
eleven these guys cannot be factored
further inside the Gaussian integers not
only are they Prime's in the normal
numbers but they're also Gaussian
Prime's unsplit able even when I is in
the picture and this corresponds with
the fact that a ring whose radius is the
square root of one of those Prime's will
never hit any lattice points and this
pattern right here is the irregularity
within prime numbers that we're going to
ultimately exploit and in a later video
I might explain why on earth this is
true why a prime numbers remainder when
divided by four has anything to do with
whether or not it factors inside the
Gaussian integers or said differently
whether or not it can be expressed as
the sum of two squares but here and now
we'll just have to take it as a given
the prime number two by the way is a
little special because it does factor
you can write it as one
plus I times one minus I but these two
Gaussian Prime's are a 90 degree
rotation away from each other so you can
multiply one of them by I to get the
other and that fact is going to make us
want to treat the prime number two a
little bit differently for where all of
the stuff is going so just keep that in
the back of your mind remember our goal
here is to count how many lattice points
are a given distance away from the
origin and doing this systematically for
all distances square root of n can lead
us to a formula for pi and counting the
number of lattice points with a given
magnitude like square root of 25 is the
same as asking how many Gaussian
integers have the special property that
multiplying them by their complex
conjugate gives you 25 so here's the
recipe for finding all gaussian integers
that have this property step one factor
25 which inside the ordinary integers
looks like five squared but since five
factors even further as two plus I times
2 minus I 25 breaks down as these four
gaussian Prime's step 2 organize these
into two different columns with
conjugate pairs sitting right next to
each other and once you do that multiply
what's in each column and you'll come
out with two different Gaussian integers
on the bottom and because everything on
the right is a conjugate with everything
on the left what comes out is going to
be a complex conjugate pair which
multiplies to 25 picking an arbitrary
standard let's say that the product from
that left column is the output of our
recipe now notice there are three
choices for how you can divvy up the
primes that can affect this output
pictured right here both copies of two
plus I are in the left column and that
gives us the product 3 plus 4i you could
also have chosen to have only one copy
of 2 plus I in this left column in which
case the product would be 5 or you could
have both copies of 2 plus I in that
right column in which case the output of
our recipe would have been 3 minus 4i
and those three possible outputs are all
different lattice points on a circle
with radius square root of 25
but why does this recipe not yet capture
all 12 of the lattice points remember
how I mentioned that a factorization
into Gaussian Prime's can look different
if you multiply some of them by I or
negative 1 negative I in this case you
could write the factorization of 25
differently maybe splitting up one of
those 5s as negative 1 plus 2 I times
negative 1 minus 2i and if you do that
running through the same recipe it can
affect the result you'll get a different
product out of that left column but the
only effect that this is going to have
is to multiply that total output by I or
negative 1 or negative I so as a final
step for our recipe let's say that you
have to make one of 4 choices take that
product from the left column and choose
to multiply it by 1 I negative 1 or
negative I corresponding to rotations
that are some multiple of 90 degrees
that will account for all 12 different
ways of constructing a Gaussian integer
whose product with its own conjugate is
25 this process is a little complicated
so I think the best way to get a feel
for it is to just try it out with more
examples let's say instead we were
looking at 125 which is 5 cubed in that
case we would have 4 different choices
for how to divvy up the prime conjugate
pairs into these two columns you can
either have 0 copies of 2 plus I in the
left column one copy in there 2 copies
in there
or all three of them in that left column
those four choices multiplied by the
final four choices of multiplying the
product from the left column by one or
by I or negative 1 or negative I would
suggest that there are a total of 16
lattice points a distance square root of
125 away from the origin and indeed if
you draw that circle out and count what
you'll find is that it hits exactly 16
lattice points but what if you introduce
a factor like 3 which doesn't break down
as the product of two conjugate Gaussian
Prime's
well that really MUX up the whole system
when you're divvying up the primes
between the two columns there's no way
that you can split up this 3 no matter
where you put it it leaves the columns
imbalanced and what that means is that
when you take the product of all of the
numbers in each column you're not going
to end up with a conjugate pair so for a
number like this 3 times 5 cubed which
is 375 there's actually no lattice point
that you'll hit no Gaussian integer
whose product with its own conjugate
gives you 375 however if you introduce a
second factor of 3 then you have an
option you can throw one 3 in the left
column and the other 3 in the right
column since 3 is its own complex
conjugate this leaves things balanced in
the sense that the products of the left
and right columns will indeed be a
complex conjugate pair but it doesn't
add any new options they're still going
to be a total of 4 choices for how to
divvy up those factors of 5 multiplied
by the final 4 choices of multiplying by
1
I negative 1 or negative I so just like
the square root of 125 Circle this guy
is also going to end up hitting exactly
16 lattice points
let's just sum up where we are when
you're counting up how many lattice
points lie on a circle with a radius
square root of n the first step is to
factor N and 4 prime numbers like 5 or
13 or 17 which factor further into a
complex conjugate pair of Gaussian
Prime's the number of choices they give
you will always be one more than the
exponent that shows up with that factor
on the other hand 4 prime factors like 3
or 7 or 11 which are already Gaussian
Prime's and cannot be split if they show
up with an even power you have one and
only one choice with what to do with
them but if it's an odd exponent you're
screwed and you just have zero choices
and always no matter what you have those
final four choices at the end by the way
I do think that this process right here
is the most complicated part of the
video it took me a couple times to think
through that yes this is a valid way to
count lattice points so don't be shy if
you want to pause and scribble things
down to get a feel for it the one last
thing to mention about this recipe is
how factors of two affect the count if
your number is even then that factor of
two breaks down as 1 plus I times 1
minus I so you can divvy up that complex
conjugate pair between the two columns
and at first it might look like this
doubles your options depending on how
you choose to place those two Gaussian
Prime's between the columns
however since multiplying one of these
guys by I gives you the other one when
you swap them between the columns the
effect that that has on the output from
the left column is to just multiply it
by I or by negative I so that's actually
redundant with the final step where we
take the product of this left column and
choose to multiply it either by one I
negative 1 or negative I what this means
is that a factor of 2 or any power of 2
doesn't actually change the count at all
it doesn't hurt but it doesn't help for
example a circle with radius square root
of 5 hits 8 lattice points and if you
grow that radius to square root of 10
then you also
eight lattice points and the square root
of 20 also hits eight lattice points as
does square root of 40 factors of two
just don't make a difference now what's
about to happen is number theory at its
best we have this complicated recipe
telling us how many lattice points sit
on a circle with radius square root of N
and it depends on the prime
factorization of n to turn this into
something simpler something we can
actually deal with we're gonna exploit
the regularity of primes that those
which are 1 above a multiple of 4 split
in two distinct Gaussian prime factors
while those that are 3 above a multiple
of 4 cannot be split to do this let's
introduce a simple function 1 which I'll
label with the Greek letter Chi for
inputs that are 1 above a multiple of 4
the output of chi is just 1 if it takes
in an input 3 above a multiple of 4 then
the output of chi is negative 1 and then
on all even numbers
it gives 0 so if you evaluate chi on the
natural numbers it gives this very nice
cyclic pattern 1 0 negative 1 0 and then
repeat indefinitely and this cyclic
function Chi has a very special property
it's what's called a multiplicative
function if you evaluate it on two
different numbers and multiply the
results like Chi of 3 times Chi of 5
it's the same as if you evaluate Chi on
the product of those two numbers in this
case Chi of 15 likewise Chi of 5 times
Chi of 5 is equal to Chi of 25 and no
matter what two natural numbers you put
in there this property will hold go
ahead try it if you want so for our
central question of counting lattice
points in this way that involves
factoring a number what I'm going to do
is write down the number of choices we
have
but using Chi in what it first seems
like a much more complicated way but
this has the benefit of treating all
prime factors equally
for each prime power like five cubed
what you write down is Chi of 1 plus Chi
of 5 plus Chi of 5 squared plus Chi of 5
cubed you add up the value of Chi on all
the powers of this prime up to the one
that shows up inside the factorization
in this case since 5 is 1 above a
multiple of 4 all of these are just 1 so
this sum comes out to be 4 which
reflects the fact that a factor of 5
cubed gives you four options for how to
divvy up the two Gaussian prime factors
between the columns for a factor like 3
to the fourth what you write down looks
totally similar chi have 1 plus Chi of 3
on and on up to chi of 3 to the 4th but
in this case since Chi of 3 is negative
1 this sum oscillates it goes 1 minus 1
plus 1 minus 1 plus 1 and if it's an
even power like for in this case the
total sum comes out to be 1 which
encapsulates the fact that there is only
one choice for what to do with those
unsplit of all threes but if it's an odd
power that sum comes out to 0 indicating
that you're screwed you can't place that
unsplit of all 3 when you do this for a
power of 2 what it looks like is 1 plus
0 plus 0 plus 0 on and on since Chi is
always 0 on even numbers and this
reflects the fact that a factor of 2
doesn't help but it doesn't hurt you
always have just one option for what to
do with it and as always we keep a 4 in
front to indicate that final choice of
multiplying by 1 I 1 or negative I we're
getting close to the culmination now
things are starting to look organized so
take a moment pause and ponder make sure
everything feels good up to this point
take the number 45 as an example this
guy factors as 3 squared times 5 so the
expression for the total number of
lattice points is 4 times pi of 1 plus
Chi of 3 plus kind of 3 squared times pi
of 1 plus Chi of 5 you can think about
this as 4 times the one choice for what
to do with the threes times 2 choices
for how to divvy up the Gaussian prime
factors of 5
it might seem like expanding out this
sum is really complicated because it
involves all possible combinations of
these prime factors and it kind of is
however because Chi is multiplicative
each one of those combinations
corresponds to a divisor of 45 I mean in
this case what we get is 4 times Chi of
1 plus Chi of 3 plus Chi of 5 plus Chi
of 9 plus Chi of 15 plus Chi of 45 and
what you'll notice is that this covers
every number that divides evenly into 45
once and only once and it works like
this for any number there's nothing
special about 45 and that to me is
pretty interesting and I think wholly
unexpected this question of counting the
number of lattice points a distance
square root of n away from the origin
involves adding up the value of this
relatively simple function over all the
divisors of n to bring it all together
remember why we're doing this the total
number of lattice points inside a big
circle with radius R should be about pi
times R squared but on the other hand we
can count those same lattice points by
looking through all of the numbers n
between 0 and R squared and Counting how
many lattice points are a distance
square root of n from the origin let's
go ahead and just ignore that origin dot
with radius 0 it doesn't really follow
the pattern of the rest and one little
dot isn't gonna make a difference as we
let our grow towards infinity now from
all of this Gaussian integer and
factoring and Chi function stuff that
we've been doing the answer for each n
looks like adding up the value of Chi on
every divisor of n and then multiplying
by 4 and for now let's just take that 4
and put it in the corner and remember to
bring it back later
at first adding up the values for each
one of these rows seems super random
right
I mean numbers with a lot of factors
have a lot of divisors where as prime
numbers will always only have two
divisors so it initially seems like you
would have to have perfect knowledge of
the distribution of primes to get
anything useful out of this but if
instead you organize these into columns
the puzzle starts to fit together how
many numbers between 1 and R squared
have 1 as a divisor well all of them so
our sum should include R squared times
Chi of 1 how many of them have two as a
divisor well about half of them so that
would account for about R squared over 2
times Chi of 2 about a third of these
rows have Chi of 3 so we can put in R
squared divided by 3 times Chi of 3 and
keep in mind we're being approximate
since R squared might not perfectly
divide 2 or 3 but as R grows towards
infinity this approximation will get
better and when you keep going like this
you get a pretty organized expression
for the total number of lattice points
and if you factor out that R squared and
then bring back the 4 that needs to be
multiplied in what it means is that the
total number of lattice points inside
this big circle is approximately 4 times
R squared times this sum and because Chi
is 0 on every even number and it
oscillates between 1 and negative 1 for
odd numbers this sum looks like 1 minus
1/3 plus 1/5 minus 1 7 and so on and
this is exactly what we wanted what we
have here is an alternate expression for
the total number of lattice points
inside a big circle which we know should
be around pi times R squared and the
bigger R is the more accurate both of
these estimates are so the percent error
between the left hand side and the right
hand side can get arbitrarily small so
divide out by that R squared and this
gives us an infinite sum that should
converge to PI and keep in mind I just
think this is really cool
the
reason that this sum came out to be so
simple requiring relatively low
information to describe ultimately stems
from the regular pattern and how prime
numbers factor inside the Gaussian
integers if you're curious there are two
main branches of number theory algebraic
number theory and analytic number theory
very loosely speaking the former deals
with new number systems things like
these Gaussian integers that you and I
looked at and a lot more and the latter
deals with things like the Riemann zeta
function or its cousins called L
functions which involve multiplicative
functions like this central character
Chi from our story and the paths that we
just walked is a little glimpse at where
those two fields intersect and both of
these are pretty heavy-duty fields with
a lot of active research and unsolved
problems so if all this feels like
something that takes time to mentally
digest like there's more patterns to be
uncovered and understood it's because it
is and there are
[Music]
[Music]